it's no big secret money helps
candidates get elected but there are
limits right like for example you as an
individual can only give $2,700 to any
candidate or you could vote but
individuals aren't what fund
multi-million dollar campaigns that win
elections
it's shadier than that I'm sure you've
heard of super PACs those giant vessels
of cash for candidates well there's
something even worse it's called dark
money but it's packaged in a bright way
the way it works is big donors give to
Social Welfare nonprofits and unlike
super PACs those nonprofits never have
to reveal where the money is coming from
in 2012 they spent over two hundred and
fifty million dollars in the
presidential race that's up from 85
million in 2008 and 3 million in 2004
the primary purpose of these nonprofits
can't be political but it is because
they end up spending just under half of
their budget I eat not the majority to
support a particular candidate like the
conservative solutions project which is
funded nearly all of Marco Rubio's ads
what do they do with the rest of their
money they buy what are called issue ads
which aren't considered political
spending because they don't directly
tell you to vote for a certain candidate
they just tell you about an issue when I
found out that the insurance company
we're denying coverage for the therapy
that senior needed
I believe except then they not so subtly
tell you to vote for a certain candidate
Thom Tillis understood those challenges
so he's advocate weird regular people
and Thom Tillis saw me and he fought for
it that was from the group carolina
rising' whose five million dollar
campaign successfully unseated a
democratic senator in 2014 almost all of
the group's funding came from a 4.8
million dollar contribution from one
anonymous donor again though they have
to report their political spending these
nonprofits never have to disclose who
gave them all the cash on Carolina
risings tax form they also didn't bother
to hide the fact that they were directly
spending money on candidates but when
asked if they engaged in political
campaigning they said no they just talk
about the issues nonprofits also get
around that whole not being political
issue by giving grants to similarly
minded organizations to help educate the
public on their favorite issues that's
how billionaire donors the Koch brothers
prefer to do things in 2012 three
nonprofits they're linked to funneled
money into their mothership nonprofit
Americans for Prosperity that group then
spent thirty three million dollars
fighting Democrats in federal elections
what about the 2016 elections groups
have already spent twenty times more
money than they did at the same point in
the 2012 election and the cash keeps
piling up so just how much dark money
will end up fueling this presidential
race and how can we stop American
democracy from being sold to the highest
bidder